rob kardashian and blac chyna's daughter
dream officially starts kindergarten
family is super important to me chyna
rob's ex-fiance shared these sweet pics
on instagram calling it a proud mom
moment how our little king and little
dream we love watching you raise them oh
my god like they're amazing yeah yeah
they're doing well yeah dream really is
living the life her first day of school
comes not long after this exciting
getaway celebrating aunt khloe
kardashian's 38th birthday dream is
honestly one of the most incredible
little girls in the entire world and
judging by all the family fun had on the
trip this five-year-old's gonna have the
best what i did with my summer stories
in class
[Music]
dreams famous fam documented tons of
activities on the trip starting with
their flight on kylie jenner's private
jet they also indulged in b-day cake and
we got a rare rob sighting
[Music]
the reclusive reality star posted this
pic stretched out and relaxing i can
have those memories and just have a
happy life and check out these snapchats
the proud dad shared from the vacay
here's his little one posing on a boat
we're gonna say she gets it from her
mama i just feel like having like a good
relationship with the other parent and
co-parenting is like a healthy type of
thing and it's something that a lot of
people need to like practice
then there's this snap dream enjoying
the good life with a drink with all that
summer r r we're guessing dream is more
than ready to get to work at school
something we know is important to this
fam it seems like nobody wants to work
these days of course kris jenner's
granddaughter inherited the family work
ethic yes i won i wanted one and
one-on-one you're doing amazing sweetie
she just joined chris aka lovey for a
commercial gig absolutely nailing an
impression of the momager's most iconic
keeping up quotes so what's the latest
jeff living life that's exactly what i
wanted to talk about today when your
kids your babies have babies it's magic
it really is yeah chris loves her
grandkids i'm so lucky because we all
live very close to each other so i get
to see my grandchildren very often like
every day
so it's the best it's just the best you
see them grow up and you know change and
we're thankful to be along for the ride
when i see baby dream for the first time
i'm definitely happy to see that she's
healthy she's just a little cute baby
it's pretty wild now she's here with us
it's pretty cool fast forward five years
and it's pretty cool to see dream off to
school
[Music]
you